[Musik]
[Applaus]
völlig cool oder herr doktor ich weiß
dass ich den habe von daher haben sie am
meisten angst dunkelheit enge räume
geheimbünde oder normal wenn
verschwörungstheorien
da haben sie am meisten sie stimmen halt
alle ist das sowas lieblings verstößt
die berliner flughafen
es gibt eine verschwörung in der
regierung dass der mit absicht nicht
fertig gebaut wird und jetzt können sie
es ja sagen es stimmt das ja sie sind
der richtige mann für unseren
illuminaten raum
[Musik]
lieber herr tauber
sie wurden vom orden der illuminati
auserwählt um sich in den dienst der
bruderschaft zu stellen weil die
charakterliche stärke ungebrochenen
willen und moralische reinheit
mitbringen gut und weil sie gerade zeit
hatten sie müssen sich sie müssen uns
zur erleuchtung führen finden sie die
vier symbole der vier elemente und
führen sie zusammen
glaube ich ja glauben sie gott ist sauer
auf die cdu mann der baut uns diese
schöne welt und sie pusten alles mit
feinstaub wieder zu gott sagen das sind
wir das ja nicht alleine
dann ist er auf alles sauber aber da
kann ich sie beruhigen ich weiß nicht ob
sie an gott glauben es grundsätzlich nie
sah er hat uns lieb
ein mann oder eine frau kommt nicht
eigentlich immer auf die botschaft an
und die wäre lieber glaube liebe
hoffnung gut ob sie das heute retten
wird weiß ich es nicht aber es kann
vielleicht das rüstzeug weil man sonst
keine ahnung hat das denn
was glauben sie welches video hat der
cdu mehr geschadet dass diese video oder
julia klöckners video mit dem nestlé
chef auf lange sicht das risiko hier
vier elemente im zusammenführen finden
wir zusammen führen und das sind vor
allem auch aus den räumen hier raus
[Musik]
sie haben jetzt herr tauber die
möglichkeit buße zu tun
ich wurde ja tatsächlich so einiges vor
da kann man jetzt mal user tun ja es gab
es ist muss kurve mobbingvorwürfe den
tweet mit den drei jungs wollen sie am
meisten den täter die anderen sachen
nicht bei den anderen beiden sachen war
kein gab es keinen echten grund okay so
aber jetzt wieder zurück zum herzen ja
ich habe spiegel und ich habe eine
spiegelverkehrte schrift im einklang
eurer stimmen noch wir sollen jetzt
versenkt finden findet ihr den rechten
weg und sucht vers 5 oder 3 steht noch
und man sucht fels 530
[Musik]
hier in der sehr kluger sie haben ja
gehört wir müssen diesen vers zusammen
singen ach so das ist dieser vers 503
von santix grünen grab in dem als loch
durch die haben sich sehr gut ein
lass dich von
luft
[Musik]
ahu
herr
und vier problem 6 zu 4
dass ich dachte ich mir jetzt noch mal
den rest aber so umgehen wie schnell
weiter und jetzt wird's noch mal richtig
aufregend hier vorliegt jetzt wird es
richtig aufbringt haben sie angst dass
hier auch na ja sie angst ein bisschen
spielen dass wir unsere terror
das war so mitteln jaja das hier ist
wieder ende gelände richtig
schön gehackt werden da warum macht die
klimaerwärmung ihrer parteivorsitzenden
weniger als die tatsache dass
transgender menschen eine eigene
toilette kommt auf das unisex toiletten
gibt oder nicht ist in der tat keine
wirklich wichtige frage trotzdem
schaffens zeitungen damit schlagzeilen
zu erfüllen und wenn man keine antwort
gibt sagen die der ist doof also muss
man leider so manchmal wirklich
unwichtigen dingen was sagen anstatt
sich mit dem wichtigen zu beschäftigen
weil es tun sie erzählen reserve gesagt
wie witzig fanden sie den witz auf einer
skala von 1 bis 10
ich entnehme ich nicht mehr so genau an
dem fall auf na ja meine art von witzen
ist es nicht es war 0
dann müssten wir hier reinkommen wir
müssen wir müssen daher kommt mir
erstmal in der kiste
ach da ist ja auch noch was drin
sehr schön erst mal mein schlüssel
anschluss soll dann geht es hier weiter
der totenkopf mit dem brief bringen sie
mal den ton kopf des ganzen schädel nach
dem tee trinken
durch den schnellen dessen schädel ist
dass das ist ein geschenk an ist dass
der kopf wieso das
damit sie es möglich gewesen das haben
wir doch gerne gemacht gut das ist
sozusagen ein element das wir mitnehmen
die erde öffnen
so ist das wollen wir gehen ja klaro
hinweg die hand weg
[Musik]
geht die treppe hoch
ist das auch gegen kinder durch
verspannung im kaminzimmer des ordens
ja es geht hier auch im sternzeichen es
geht um große gruppe glauben sie an
großgruppe nicht so wirklich aber
zulässig sind mit amüsement
also ja ein wissenschaftlicher quatsch
so wie der klimawandel den geht's ja
wirklich ach so also den gibt's sowieso
und den gegner laufen menschen gemacht
das ja der streit ist ja ob der mensch
einfluss aufs klima und ja hatte hat er
warum sie trump ist zum beispiel anlass
wieso kann man das du jemandem nicht
machen was ist da in seinem kopf los ich
glaube dass er so ein beispiel dafür ist
dass es leider viele menschen gibt die
einfach fakten wissenschaftliche fakten
ignorieren und die tun halt manchmal
weil sie einen zwingen etwas zu ändern
und deswegen gibt es menschen die sagen
auch wenn das alles nicht stimmt kann
ich also weitermachen wie bisher
[Musik]
sie haben keine ahnung was das ist das
ist ein ganzes jahr die schauen sie doch
mal hier
die beiden zwillings sterne ja und dann
einmal so ums eck und wieder zurück
waren erzählt das wasser man ja nicht
stimmt sie haben seepferdchen
seepferdchen zieht den wagen vom wasser
machen und deswegen kommt jetzt ein
das kreuzchen ruft oder die eule nehmen
sie die räume mal ansicht der vogel der
weisheit der vogel ist natürlich ein
element das heißt wir haben jetzt mit
ressourcen der erde
wir haben mit der eule die luft die luft
jetzt brauchen wir noch wasser sehen sie
ich gebe mal die sehen ja hier
verschiedene bilder an der wand mankell
wir haben aus der heiligen stadt aus rom
verschiedene gebäude sehr gut dann haben
wir darum glaube ich ihnen eine karte
von rom sehr gut sehr gut
ja mit einer kette ja und was müssen wir
jetzt machen jetzt das wahrscheinlich
verbinden
sehr richtig die frage ist nur in
welcher reihenfolge was schätzen die
welcher reihenfolge wird immer sagen
uhrzeigersinn hat sich bewährt aber okay
dann probiere es einfach raus
[Musik]
die schlüssel erst einmal den schlüssel
das könnte was mit den illuminati zu tun
haben
sie sind also
eine botschaft
ja wieder einzahlen wofür könnte der
zahlencode und sage haben wahrscheinlich
noch irgendwo hier haben wir doch noch
eine truhe 654 ist dass der heilige gral
leider nein warum hast du jetzt schon
sehr schade ein schäbiges requisit in
sibiu die zeigt ja und rennt die zeit
ist so dramatisch jetzt muss die musik
der einspieler tisch zu legen
also ich habe jetzt ein bisschen hier
die eule und der filter nur 1 ja und
jetzt so und so meint jetzt mal gas
geben mir die letzten sekunden
jahrhundert und richtig machen
wir haben wir haben noch zeit ich habe
kein bisschen spannung erzeugen wollen
alles gut geklappt und wir sind fast am
ende wahrscheinlich unsere einzige
gemeinsamkeit mit der gruppe passt was
haben wir noch viel gemeinsamkeit nicht
sagen ich war fast am ende
ach so das einzige fast gut
dann gilt es jetzt natürlich sie haben
das richtig gesehen
wir haben nur drei elemente ja das haben
wir doch da eigentlich es sind nicht die
kerzen sie mein denken ist etwas anderes
das hier zu finden ist
das ist beim rauchen wollen wir uns kurz
berauschen und sie sind der
gütertrennung garagen glaube ich das bin
ich ja alles gut
gutes geil egal wie man sich das
vorgestellt hat die katholische kirche
schon gut gedient
es gab plötzlich ein messer bei uns der
hat extra immer das so bringe art mit
über minuten deswegen ganz gern mal eine
messe ja was ich gerne folgen egal jetzt
müssen wir folgendes machen wir haben
die altardecke was macht aber mit einer
alte architekt liegt man auf den altar
wahnsinnig scharf kombiniert das machen
wir jetzt mal mit alten decken kennen
sie sich als messdiener hat und noch
aber viel besser aus als ich ja durchaus
gut so jetzt muss es im prinzip genauso
gelegt wird wie es dort stehen also aqua
ist was aqua ist das ja denke ich dass
fahrzeugen ein schädel ist das hier ist
das feuerwehrmuseum
halleluja
[Musik]
wir sind gerüstet
ach so erstmal nur erleuchtet ich dachte
befreit wir sind erstmal erleichtert und
jetzt für sie erleuchtet sind der tauber
in welche partei werden sie jetzt
wechseln ich konnte ich melde mich
freiwillig nach afghanistan
das ist das ziel nein ich bleibe in der
cdu glaub ich fühle mich da ganz gut
dann sind sie nicht erleuchtet aber sie
haben trotzdem gewonnen das ist das
absurde an diesem spiel das licht brennt
und gleich wird sich die die tür öffnet
sich ja wir können ihnen ausschreiten
gut nehmen ist ein bisschen mit würde
die haben also in die hand so und jetzt
ein bisschen geschafft
alles ist gut
erneut sah ich bin jetzt erleuchtet
illuminati und so wenn wir unseren
geheimorden beitreten wollt müsst ihr
nur drei dinge tun erstens drückt auf
gefällt mir wenn euch das video gefallen
hat zweitens abonniert diesen kanal und
drittens schreibt euch noch ein video
der heute show an und ich muss jetzt
gehen
dieses gespräch hat niemals
stattgefunden
ok